j'ai été plusieurs fois en présence
quand on vous dit que vous avez duper
les gens avouerez pénurie coin ben non
je me suis servi des médias je me suis
la voix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
babar des ventes un peu particulière est
dans le dur en ce bas le bien était déjà
occupée donc il va falloir
faire partie entre guillemets les
personnes qui sont dedans alors laurent
elodie ont-ils menti à la france
d'accord vous avez effectivement j'ai
cette page 19 ces épreuves 19 l'agent
immobilier avait oublié mais bon vu que
c'est que la connaissance d'une
connaissance c'était pas nous avait pas
menti vous n'étiez pas au courant que la
maison était squatté millions le reste
oui bernard alors ça c'est faux vous
savez quand vous achetez une maison il
ya un acte notarié pardon hein il ya un
pardon mais en tout cas c'est la valider
ce que je dis il ya un acte notarié on
vous donne les clés socle était précisée
dans l'acte de vente a pas que vous
étiez huissier de justice et justice
mais bon là c'est les notaires c'est un
peu différent mais là c'était marqué sur
l'acte de vente c'était marqué
occupation sans droit ni titre pourquoi
parce qu'il savait et monsieur savais
que quelqu'un était dedans dans la vidéo
avec l'agent immobilier une dame on voit
très bien qu'elle dit il n'y a pas eu de
remise de clés il faudra maintenant
faire partir les gens qui sont là bas et
votre cette vidéo elle ne date pas
d'hier elle date de très longtemps et
quand vous allez devant la maison pour
les médias avec un trousseau terre
d'envoyer je peux pas rentrer ce sont
des fausses clés vous le savez laurent
vous ne pouvez pas nier ça la halle à ce
jour là effectivement j'avais pu je
n'avais pas les clés avec moi il me
demandait de prendre entre ce que les de
faire comme si c'était des clés de sa
vous reconnaissez la mise en scène et le
mensonge abbas et il m'a demandé de
faire ça je vendrai prend un trou avec
toi normalement j'ai un peu d'empathie
pour les gens qui se sentent lésés avec
un avec un grand b mais là je dois
avouer que j'en ai pas parce que c'est
pas possible ça veut dire je dis pas que
vous mentez parce que moi je vous
connais pas enfin voila je dis pas que
vous montez mais c'est impossible
d'acheter un bien deux fois moins cher
que le prix du marché est passé chez un
notaire le notaire il est une obligation
il est une obligation de vous dire ce
bien là il ya un truc c'est pas possible
tu coûtes ce prix là l'acte de vente que
vous avez montré parfait mais il peut
avoir des avenants donc il nous faut
tous le compromis je peux acheter un
bien 140000 euros vous 2 et à un bien
qui vaut trois cent mille euros la jetée
140000 euros et que le notaire ne disent
rien c'est impossible moi où je t'en
veux laurent je vais te parler
franchement c'est que tu nous a pas dit
quand tu es venu que tu avais pas les
clés et tu savais très bien qu'ils
avaient des squatteurs dessus et nous
tout le plateau même toute la france on
a eu de l'empathie pour toi et ta
fiancée on a voulu vous sauver on a
voulu faire des trucs
en fait au final on se rend compte que
tu savais c'est tout pareil bar est
ouvert c'est une merguez non mais bon c
est pas fait pour être grossier et nous
a pris pour des cons tout nourri la
france entière et nous a pris pour des
cons tu achète une maison et que tu sais
qu'elle est squat était plus une victime
est au courant ça ne veut pas dire
attends ça veut pas dire que il est
content et qui pensait qu'il allait
rentrer plus vite et c'est en ça veut
pas dire ça mais pas pardon dans tous
les droits
je suis désolé tu appelles victimes
quand moi j'achète un immeuble qui est
squatté et que je prévois de le remettre
à louer en six mois et qu'en fin de
compte ça prend deux ans j'ai pris mon
risque mon risque c'est de le sous payés
jamais combien voulu dépasser entre le
moment où vous avez visité la maison il
y avait juste un matelas et vous ai dit
bon bah ça doit être un squatteur ou des
petits jeunes de temps en temps et quand
vous y êtes revenu et qu'il y avait
vraiment le chien les rideaux et les
meubles en septembre mais c'est passé
huit mois huit mois de juin neuf mois et
pendant ces huit mois là vous êtes
jamais retourné non ah bon vous avez
avec tous leurs avocats envoyer
quelqu'un pour vérifier les travaux ne
serait ce que pour les tu ne te sens pas
venir les professionnels de l'immobilier
nous on en attend nos
travaux à faire tu dois encore pour
faire un devis tu dis il ya la chaudière
a le truc donc toi mais cinquante mille
de travaux ou 200 milles c'est pareil
sa motion alors si vous ne connaissez
pas moi mais des nids à chaque fois
c'est vrai qu'ici tu meurs très connu
moi je la dois très drôle spécialisée
dans le foot
[Musique]
mais possible ces scandales
qui bouffent des poids
et en accord avec une marque ou s'ils
refusent de faire ça parce que si je
casse ma télé au moment où la casse la
marque à la part et ça gâche un peu le
truc et on peut dire qu'une marque ma
démarche et faudrait traiter pas se
mentir non j'ai pas sponsoring je les
achète avec mes propres moyens et moi
j'ai toujours dit les télés c'est comme
les prostituées personne ne les paye en
fait c'est moi c'est moi qui ai
je suis à des fans qui limite pour la
maison et la non justement mais ils
peuvent pas se permettre donc justement
ce que je fais moi c'est que comme les
rockeurs qui cassent et
ça reste une vidéo le prix d'une télé
centre 300 400 jours un rapport qu'elle
sort un clip ses vingt trente mille
quarante mille euros ouais au final
c'est un budget de 300 à certains qui me
déprime
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça c'est le budget du coup ça m'a fait
un scooter des mers
avait répété avant ça en fait c'est ça
qui est fou dans mes vidéos c'est que
j'ai le droit à une prise incessamment
c'est une télé je peux pas à casser raté
ma vie dans la roue construit ses
proches que karim benzema c'est chaud là
d'or 1 karim aussi il ya eu enfin là il
a vécu il ya un an qui a beaucoup pesé
je pense que giroud
est ce qu il a le potentiel pour être
titulaire attaque là ça va être vite
fait les mecs
ne confonds pas la f1 on ne confond pas
la f1 et le karting et je suis gentil
voilà maintenant next je parle même
secte riquet karting moi je sais de
chlef la non mais là ça sort du langage
codé du langage codifié qu'on a
d'habitude et si c'était pas vous il
n'aurait jamais dit ça tu m'aimes
arrivions pg je sus tout laisse book de
paname la vie de ma mère j'avais déjà
dit une fois mais c'est risqué là je
suis sérieux vous êtes sérieux ou causer
pété les plombs
[Applaudissements]
m pas mal à disposition et à l'époque en
2010 et conteuse et neymar bien au psg
c'était le j'y croyais vraiment pas
toujours été prêt à couper impossible
qui viennent
j'avais dit que j'avais sous cet os book
de paname aujourd'hui c'est tout laisse
book de paname qu'ils me sucent donc on
a inversé un peu là pourquoi t'es pas
clair toi
alors les victimes d'hier doit-elle être
les coupables de demain après la
révélation de sa lourde mise en examen
dans la presse ce soit laurent est de
retour dans tpm p
merci m toledano des travailleurs de
remerciement merci laurent suffire pour
la troisième fois ouais tu vas être
chroniqueur laurent cette histoire est
complètement folle on va de
rebondissement en rebondissement
déjà en action est ce que vous êtes dans
la maison oui vous y êtes universal
n'est pas reparti les travaux avancent
bien ça avance d'après nos informations
vous avez déjà fait de la prison florent
est ce que c'est vrai a eu 8 passes qui
voudra bien sûr de sûr j'espère qu'il
dira la vérité mais avait dit la vérité
j'ai été plusieurs fois présenté alors
oui c'est vrai on a le droit de purger
sa peine et d'avoir fédéré par le roi
j'ai pas droit donc j'ai parents
d'acheter une maison c'est ça c'est sûr
que c'est surtout que c'est à c'est à ma
compagne la maison
entièrement à ma compagne aurait t on la
maison était achetée par votre compagne
oui oui entièrement voilées pas mis un
euro dans la maison qu'est ce que ça a à
voir avec le trafic de stupéfiants
qu'est-ce que ça à voir on dévoilement
casier on dévoile tout je vois pas trop
alors laurent et quand on vous dit que
vous avez dû piler gens vont rythmer
d'eric roy maintenant je me suis servi
des médias je me suis je ne vois pas en
médiatisant la faire vous saviez que
peut être potentiellement ça allait
sortir d'un risque que vous preniez
banon casier judiciaire du som ça me
dérange pas du tout après je viens ici
je vous le dis on a aujourd'hui vous
êtes train d'être mis en examen encore
oui je suis mis en examen on va être
jugé je pense fin d'année aux effets
huit mois de placard non je fais six
mois et demi je pense qu'ils m'ont dit
c'est fini comment vous c'est fini mais
voilà et vous achetez la maison à quel
moment par rapport à votre incarcération
jeu sort le 9 mai je l'achète le 19 mai
et géraldine avait raison il ya deux
jours a dit mais pourquoi pendant sept
mois faisait pas partie vérifier et il
n'a pas voulu en parler parce qu'ils les
poches des jeux
allez donc les temps pedro n'a pas pu
savoir que pendant ces sept mois il ya
quelqu'un de lambres ah bah non il
obligé de raconter sa vie ce matin
j'écoutais la radio et j'habite urbain
oui il a vu l'a vu la maison sept mois
avant trois-quatre fois c'est évident
après il a signé quand il est sorti
enfin sa femme a signé avec lui et donc
mais il n'a pas vu entre-temps donc
n'étant présent il
est en suisse est alors donc avoir du
tout non sa fin mais le pape arrive le
barbecue c'est un petit peu un silence
qu'une raison d'expliquer aujourd'hui ce
parisien la première fois qu'il est
qu'il a un casier judiciaire on revient
pas il postule pas points dans la police
ou pour au concours miss france où il
faut avoir un casier judiciaire mais
qu'on vise c'est vrai voilà ça n'a rien
à voir il a parlé d'un squat qui virent
pas par les diverses orléans police donc
elle aucune raison de raconter tout ça
donc il n'a pas dit mais il est pas
coupable de pas l'avoir dit parce qu'on
l'a pas demandé qu'il n'a pas à le dire
ils voulaient me remettre et médine être
à vous ils vous l'avez dit m bon on n'en
a pas parlé honnêtement d'origine du
temps c'est vrai que c'est pas un garçon
qui perd le casse voilà comme ça donc il
va pas raconter sa vie on n'a peut-être
pas envie de raconter même à un avocat
parce que ça n'avait rien à voir quand
on s'est rencontrés que j'ai fait de la
prison et ses
nouvelles et les dangers de doute
surtout et d'organiser un grand défi
c'est sans doutes sur la transaction
mais le doute sur tous les pouvoirs les
lots de ces liens
avec des gens comme lui qui serait mieux
d'avoir le doute
c'est avec des gens comme ça que tu n'as
pas de deuxième chance et
sachez que les habitants vivent des
expériences paranormales depuis la mort
d'un résident en 2019 n'en peuvent plus
point de demander un logement d'urgence
comme je voulais dit on a demandé
à tous les habitants de cet immeuble de
venir témoigner aucun n'a voulu venir
témoigner par crainte vraiment je vous
dis c'est un truc de fou le seul qui a
bien voulu c'est walid habitants de cet
immeuble et il habite dans cet immeuble
qui sera en tête comme une dizaine
d'autres habitants vous demandez un
relogement vous habiter là-bas depuis
combien de temps moi j'habite je suis né
je suis né à frontenay 16 heures que je
suis là depuis 20 ans maintenant
d'accord je sais que j'achète walid il y
encore cette choqué très sensible voilà
par tout ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui
se passe dans l'immeuble alors
il ya beaucoup de voisins qui se
plaignent qu'ils voyent des ombres
il ya beaucoup de passage des portes qui
claquent
il ya beaucoup de phénomènes vraiment
bizarre tels que les appareils qui
s'allument tout seul
et
pour ma part moi j'ai une histoire
c'était quand je rentrais un jour je
rentrais tard le soir
je rentrais dans le bâtiment extérieur
et j'ai senti une odeur très nauséabonde
des serveurs que j'avance etc et je me
dis que c'est vraiment bizarre parce que
d'habitude voilà quoi ça sentait
vraiment les égouts etc je me dis mais
ça quand j'étais à l'extérieur ça
sentait pas ça et donc j'avance et je
sens une présence derrière moi et comme
si on m'a attrapé les pôles donc moi
paniqué je me retourne d'un coup et je
vois rien du tout voilà donc c'est à
dire que depuis ce jour là j'essaye de
ne pas trop rentrer le soir tard le soir
voilà quoi c'est je me rappelais site à
fontenay-aux-roses c'est assez dense et
dans le
92 et les habitants sont terrifiés c'est
aussi pour ça qu'ils ne veulent pas
venir parce que dans leur esprit il y a
des forces presque entre guillemets
maléfique il ya du mal dans le
l'immeuble c'est à dire que après la
mort du résident il ya des gens qui dans
la vie quotidienne est bouleversée c'est
ça ils ne peuvent plus vivre et
apparemment le maire ces biens est venu
mais c'est pas une situation suffisantes
pour avoir un relogement monsieur va
peut-être nous le dira mais il ya une
présence il ya des forces qu'on peut
qualifier de culte mais très concrète
qui bouleverse leur vie assez dramatique
et on le voit vous êtes très courageux
d'être venu parce que ces gens se
demandent s'ils parlent qu'est ce qui va
leur arriver on en est là que ma voisine
tuyaux qui m'a raconté que sa fille
avait vu quelque chose et elle avait
suivi sa fille est en fait sa team
montré du doigt quelque chose mais que
voilà corps elle avait vu un petit
enfant courir dans les enfants alors à
la criée enfin voilà qu'à la criée et
ans l'enfant mais elle était encore un
petit alors pour moi moi je ressens deux
entités à la basse au soir je suis
médium depuis 35 ans et que j'ai évolué
progressivement sur de la chasse aux
fantômes et sur tout ce qui touche les
phénomènes paranormaux en devenant
experts de cette partie aujourd'hui il
faut savoir que dans
les maisons dans les hlm il y a aussi
des entités se promènent mais qui
changera à la suite d'un décès et moi je
sortais effectivement de une petite
fille - une petite fille et je pense
qu'il est parce qu il ya trop de
phénomènes paranormaux qui s'échelonne
sur plusieurs étages et sur plusieurs
maisons quand je dis de saison quitté
est ce qu'elles peuvent voilà faire du
mal psychologiquement 6 rebonds ou est
ce que c'est parce que c'est la fatigue
qui fait que ya dedans c'est l'immeuble
énormément de dépression oui les
habitants sont au bout du rouleau sais
ce que c'est parce qu'ils sont fatigués
parce qu'ils sont ils sont sous pression
mais c'est ce qui se passe tout
simplement c'est qu'on n'est pas habitué
on n'est pas confronté tout le temps à
ce genre de phénomène donc ça fait peur
mais en fin de compte ce que je dis
toujours moi les fantômes sont gentils
fantômes cd ils sont très gentils ils
veulent simplement rentrer en contact
avec nous moi j'ai eu un cas il ya
quelques années avec un monsieur qui
avait construit sa maison et qui est
décédé et ne voulait pas que sa maison
soit vendu parce que c'était lui qui
avait construit cette maison et parce
que il était attaché à cette maison et
il avait demandé à sa femme de ne pas
vendre cette maison et sa femme quand il
est parti et vas à la banque de la
maison et ce qui s'est passé c'est que
pendant le compromis et les actes
authentiques de vente la maison a brûlé
a changé des choses à vos parents ma
mère ti-cats voix des fois des présences
dans le [ __ ] ou quoi et comme visite
il était né aussi qui s'allument chez
vous et allez salut we had accorde un
moment dans la nuit oui pendant la nuit
oui vous êtes tranquilles en train de
dormir il ya eu ma merde éteint la télé
et il s'avère que même la voisine il
descendit homme et il m'arrive la même
chose est-ce que parfois ces entités
vous résiste est-ce que parfois vous
échouez alors moi il m'est arrivé aussi
la même question
il m'est arrivé d'aller dans des
endroits où j'avais fait une émission
pour m6 par exemple et on avait trouvé
effectivement une entité dans cette
maison et la personne qui habitait ce
lieu avait confirmé tout ce que je
voyais tout ce que je disais et je lui
dis on fait quoi maintenant un média ont
fait rien parce que moi je suis très
bien avec elle ça m'est arrivé en radio
comme je le disais de capter des des
personnes comme ça sur des animateurs
connus c'est injuste ans a été dix fois
sur des animateurs connus ils avaient
des entités derrière eux we kiss a beau
[Musique]
grand père c'était sur une matinale sur
virgin il m'avait invité pour halloween
et puis on trouvera isolée en disant oui
bah est ce que vous êtes capable de nous
dire si il ya une entité là et puis je
dis moi on parle de quelqu'un s'appelle
pierre seel fou qui est décédé il ya pas
longtemps se sont planqués présent et
crise a fait ou là c'est mon grand-père
jours
de témoignages de femmes victimes
d'agressions sexuelles affluent sur les
réseaux sociaux cette semaine c'est la
chanteuse luan qui aurait été victime de
vertiges et de vomissements alors
qu'elle sortait d'un bar dans le 18ème
arrondissement de paris
l'a vite pris en charge par un médecin
les symptômes qui a décrit s'apparente à
une consommation de ghb la personne va
être un peu ces dates et un peu
somnolent tu es tu ne vas pas enregistré
ce qui se passe qu'est ce que c'est que
le ghb le jaish b c'est une drogue c'est
une drogue
on appelle ecstasy liquide donc xl mikit
c'est quoi c'est propriété florissante
propriétés aphrodisiaques mais aussi
propriété amnésiante c'est à dire que on
peut en prendrait un peu ne plus rien se
rappeler à cesser tout ça alors les
effets donc on les avait donné ça dure
combien de temps les effets les effets
sont très très très rapide on en 15 30
minutes ça arrive ça dure 3 3 heures en
moyenne ah ouais et après ça se dit si
on peut ne pas s'en souvenir on peut ne
pas s'en souvenir et le problème c'est
qu'il faut les doses est vite fait pour
savoir si du ghb dans le sens où dans
les urines ça qu'on appelle on l'appelle
la drogue du violeur anciens c'est un
agent de soumission chimique en fait
c'est comme l'alcool et bientôt des
épines quand ça se matérialise commencé
c'est un liquide inodore incolore et
sans saveur amère mais il le met dans
les verts déjà où il ya de l'alcool
c'est parce que le ghb il faut pas le
boire tout seul dans un verre en
plastique ça fait fondre les verres en
plastique
donc c'est extrêmement violente florian
qu'est ce qui s'est passé chez vous avez
toutes les infos sur cette affaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
mais elle est tout simplement aller
boire un verre tranquillement avec une
amie avec avec la nounou sa fille dans
un bar du xviiie arrondissement parce
qu'elle habite là-bas qu avec son
compagnon et sa fille donc et un peu
plus tard en rentrant chez elle a été
prise de vertiges de nausées de
sensations assez assez désagréable on va
dire elle a appelé son médecin tout de
suite qui est venu et qui a
immédiatement suspecté ce que décrivait
monsieur c'est à dire des symptômes dus
au ghb donc qu'il a il a ordonné en tout
cas il a préconisé car il faire les
tests les tests adéquat pour pour
vérifier s'il s'agissait bien de ghb ou
pas elle a évidemment porté plainte donc
ce qu'il faut faire à l'heure actuelle
on n'a pas les résultats des doutes elle
a dû voir peut-être quelqu'un qui était
quelqu'un qui va demander une photo qui
étaient un peu bizarres ou alors ce
qu'il raconte est en tout cas dans
l'article du parisien qui a qui ont
sorti l'info ce matin c'est que a priori
personne ne s'est approché d'eux que
personne
ne les a sollicités et c'est ce qui
était raconté ce matin après peut-être
que depuis d'autres choses c'est un cas
qui tu es et tu es vraiment mal voilà
était vraiment très très mal je retiens
la parlais tout à l'heure des boîtes de
nuit d'elliot sont souvent administrés
les doses de ghb là ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'on est un lundi à
19h30 quand méme ah bah si tu serais
plus les boîtes de nuit tous les barons
soir commence il ya un truc il ya un
truc important c'est ne jamais laisser
son verso jamais jamais jamais et même
mettre un calvaire si c'est possible
génial ça existe dans les capotes de
verre au
bar café le café standard près de chez
vous vous laissez jamais vos adversaires
il ya une enquête qui est ouverte depuis
le mois de novembre parce qu'elle est
beaucoup beaucoup de dénonciation afin
de dénonciation de deux rapports qui
ressemble à celui de luan aujourd'hui
c'est ça y est on peut faire un
parallèle avec les piqûres qui existe
aujourd'hui dans les boîtes de nuit dans
tous ces lieux la turquie dont on entend
parler malheureusement depuis des
semaines et des mois il ya une grosse
grosse montée de ces choses-là des
plaintes y en a plusieurs c'est l'alerté
tout ce qui m'a ce qui m'a réveillé et
effrayé c'est qu'elle décide de rentrer
chez elle boit elle a menti elles elles
difficilement à la paix son médecin et
ce qui est fou c'est qu'il a
immédiatement pensé une intoxication au
ghb ça veut dire que il en penser que
c'est pas un truc auquel tu penses tout
tuer ben non c'est ça qui est incroyable
c'est laurent elle est bon mais bon
c'est un médecin qui vient en urgence
que c'est à domicile il est bon quoi non
mais c'est incroyable ça veut dire
qu'ils envoient mais de toute façon il
faut y penser systématiquement
maintenant c'est un réflexe à avoir en
2022 et y ai eu plein de bars à
bruxelles notamment il ya des
associations qui
se sont mobilisées
il ya eu des cas à lille marseille
grenoble nantes paris donc la belgique
et il ya plein d'associations qui en ce
moment qu'on danse pour après rapporté à
la police hautement pour essayer voir
d'où viennent les cas donc vous avez
raison de lancer l' alerte c'est
extrêmement préoccupant je fais d'abord
si on a dit aux piqûres parce que la
plupart servent des piqûres sont vides
et apparemment c'est des jeunes qui
s'amusent à faire ça juste pour piquer
des gens mais il ya certains cas où il
ya des traces de ghb qui ont été revus
dans les piqûres c'est pas un seul
réseau ces jeunes qui pique tout le
monde en boîte de nuit à sion dans les
festivals dans les soirées sérieux
administre du ghb donc il faut faire
extrêmement attention et ce qu'il faut
porter plainte automatiquement
soumission chimique l'accord taux plein
chantier comporte bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]